you know you gotta pay for that right
hey not okay she's very much like you no
no
she can learn to be better better than
me actually yes raided our
hey youtubers happy Superbowl weekend
there's gonna be crazy new footage so
let's break it down the funny thing
about this is just the idea that she is
a feral animal and the way that
Wolverine was a feral animal when
Professor X first started working with
them so the big joke is just in this
adorable little girl being crazy
inappropriate just like Wolverine
getting ready to chop everyone's heads
off there's gonna be a whole lot more of
this this weekend from all the other
studios I'll be posting trailer videos
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a giveaway going on
that I'll explain at the end of the
video but right now this little girl is
my favorite new female character in any
Marvel movie from any studio now there
are a whole lot of really powerful
female characters but she just totally
wins you over with her craziness so
appropriate given the battle that's
gonna be happening on the football field
they're playing up the funny moments but
you see how this is a mirror of that x2
scene where Wolverine himself almost
flips out on someone when he's grabbing
a beer
[Music]
they're also hyping up it runs in the
family so they're being more open about
who she is where she comes from I did
another video about x-23 herself so add
a link at the end of this but she's
essentially a clone of Wolverine but in
the comics her relationship with Logan
is a little more contentious she's grown
to a full adult and this she's more of a
child so she becomes more of a daughter
to him the other funny thing they've
explained did you see him driving
professor X around in the back of this
car here driving her around is that when
he's been hiding out in this town on the
border of Mexico he's been working as a
limousine driver the Great and Powerful
Wolverine working as a limo driver you
can see professor X shaking his fists in
the back asking for sandwiches the funny
thing about that like we were just
talking about that x2 scene with
Wolverine in the cat in x2 he's driving
around that band of young x-men I've
always felt like Wolverine works best
when you pair him with younger
characters that are more innocent he's
this super hardcore dude who's forced to
confront his humanity when he sees these
innocent people that need his help I
don't think that's the CD player
sit back where we going
storm and Jean are in Boston we'll head
that way my parents some Mazda good in
the really cool thing that I'm excited
for really from all superhero movies
Marvel's doing this - I'll explain at
the end of the video is more intimate
small crossovers like this there have
also been a couple really important
people that have come out and explained
those comics that she's walking around
with - so it wasn't really clear from
the previous trailers just because it
was like really low res but it says
x-men comics group they're basically
fake comics that were made for the movie
by Joe casada mr. marvel himself he used
to be Marvel's creative director but he
was an artist for a long time wrote a
bunch of comics so he and another artist
made those covers specifically for this
movie just because of the weird
copyright issues with them actually
using real Marvel comics in the movies
so I know it sounds weird but it's just
meant to hype up the idea of all these
crazy adventures in the legends of the
x-men inside the universe of this film
and a lot of people were asking - about
Hugh Jackman making a comment saying
that it's not in the same universe is
the main x-men films the director James
Mangold came out after that and said
that people probably misinterpreted what
he was saying or he misspoke a little
bit because it's not completely said in
a different universe
he just said right after that
post-credit scene in Days of Future past
in the future timeline that they've
fixed where everyone's still alive if
you haven't seen that movie in a while
what happens is is that there's this
post-apocalyptic timeline with an older
version of all the characters that are
still alive they banded together with
Magneto's Brotherhood of mutants so they
send wolverine into the past to try and
change things for the better they're
successful and when wolverine wakes up
he wakes up in the x-mansion which
hasn't been destroyed and it was sort of
Bryan Singer's way to wave his hand over
all the craziness that had happened
after he left the franchise so x3 was
gone Jean Grey was alive she hadn't
become the Phoenix he wasn't forced to
kill her Professor X is back and he has
this brief memory of what used to happen
because he
reading Logan's mind and Logan's the
only one that remembers this previous
timeline you did it did what Logan don't
you have a class to teach a class to
teach that history history actually I
could use some help with that help with
what
pretty much everything after 1973 I
think the history I know is a little
different welcome back it's good to see
you Charles
it's good to see everyone well I had a
promise to keep you and I have a lot of
catching up to do yeah this movie set
many years after that Logan's buried
most of his friends he's trying to take
care of Professor X who is slowly dying
himself but still very powerful but they
released a little more footage
explaining a little bit about the
pockets of other mutants that are still
alive that they're trying to find so
it's not like they're the last mutants
on the planet but you guys can let me
know because this is said so far in the
future how do you want them to
reincorporate the characters in the
future films because I'll do a separate
video about it at some point because
it's almost like the Deadpool universe
now it the way that characters become so
popular he's influencing the way they're
thinking about doing crossover movies
they said that they're doing the Marvel
phase 4 style thing where they're gonna
do a lot of smaller crossovers mixed
with the bigger tentpole films which if
you didn't know is basically what's
happening in Marvel phase 4 they'll
still be the big Avengers crossovers but
most of the films that you see will be
crossover movies so like Iron Man
showing up in a spider-man film Winter
Soldier showing back up during Black
Panther things like that there'll be
more crossover movies they'll still be
very cool very big movies it's just that
you're headed up for a lot of people
popping up in other people's movies so
the same thing I think is going to be
happening with the DC movies and with
the x-men Fox movies so that actually
makes me really excited I totally love
these smaller films I think Logan is
gonna be amazing there's gonna be a
whole bunch more Super Bowl trailer
stuff happening this weekend so I'll try
to post that as fast as possible just
explain that giveaway I mentioned at the
beginning of the video too because the
movie is coming out in a couple weeks
which is awesome it's for IMAX gift
certificates or gift certificates even
if the movie is not in IMAX so standard
rules apply all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video I'll announce winners as I
post the new Superbowl trailer video so
make sure you check those out as I post
them as long as you have alerts enabled
you should be able to get everything but
I do have a teaser for Grant Gustin
getting a new version of the flash suit
so I'll post that
next but you guys can let me know if you
want me to do another video for that
other Wolverine Logan footage where you
wait for that to post you can click here
for more Super Bowl trailers and you can
click here to learn all about
x-23 backstory thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video